he's one of the greatest shooters in the
history of the sport he's a guy who
would love to go against his own defense
Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the third
Reggie calling games through the
regional finals with Kevin Harlan the
sportscaster of the Year Dan Bonner and
Dana Jacobson so you've got Michigan
Texas A&M and then you've got Gonzaga
against Florida State coming up Thursday
is that correct
you know in our little la little podcast
before we get into that I kind of want
to talk about your poll question because
you said would you rather be a 16 seed
and upset at number one or be an 11 seed
moving on to the sweet 16 Mike correct
on that yes I think it's almost a
no-brainer right might want to be an 11
seed you would want to be an 11 seed
yeah I want to go to the Final Four okay
that's okay that's a good well that's
different you said just to move on to
the sweet 16 obviously a lot of Chicago
still has work to be done and it will be
hopefully remembered more if they get to
the Final Four there's still a nip but
to me UMBC will live on forever they
will always be that cautionary tale
every time this comes around for a
number one don't you think
every time highlight start they will
start with you and beefy so every
tournament every single tournament from
here on out when we had the 16 seeds
that are announced they're gonna have
well remember UMBC and we liken them to
Neil Armstrong there they're the first
16 to be to one so they're the Neil
Armstrong of 16 seats and if Lola
Chicago loses that first game we won't
even remember them no but it was okay so
you've seen you saw Oklahoma Rhode
Island Iona Duke Radford Villanova
Alabama Virginia Tech Alabama Villanova
Rhode Island then you have Rhode Island
into okay
so best team that you seemed so far to
okay I'm only going to speak from as you
just mentioned what we saw Villanova and
Duke are playing
you know looking at what happened in the
south and in the West with all the
upsets those two teams are playing at
such a high clip whether it's Jay Wright
and the Wildcats in those threes I mean
whether they're from Mikkel bridges
Jalen Brunson who is a potential player
of the year and then Duke I'm not
kidding you look like an NBA team they
are the 31st NBA team we got no big oh
they look they are like locked in and I
think their size and now that they've
adopted coach Bay Hines two-three zone
defensively they are playing at a
different level so because I had eyes on
both of those teams such a high clip but
again I mean Kentucky what they did in
the SEC Tournament and how those
freshmen are playing now they're playing
very well so it anyone can be beat but
if you're asking me right now Villanova
and Duke are playing at such a high
level better than anyone else
number one pick overall Bagley eight and
somebody else I think I think it still
will be Aten from Arizona
but Bagley I mean Coach K could not stop
and obviously I mean he's seen him every
he sees him every day and he coaches him
but to put him in the same breath as
LeBron James in terms of being an elite
runner and finisher and quick jumper
because obviously Coach K has experience
in coaching the Bron with Team USA he
says his athleticism and seen it up
front how long and let's not forget he
was great he plays great with his back
to the basket but he could also face you
up and knock down threes very versatile
at the big man I would still go with
Aten as my number one because I think
he's a bigger difference maker but
Bagley is knocking on the door just
coming back helped trae young down the
road a little more or is he sort of what
he's going to be the size he's going to
be back i I haven't heard anything but I
mean I'm assuming he's not coming back
could be a lottery pick I just I don't
know if you're gonna be a lot of reap if
you're Trey young you've got to go
because your stock is
you have the highest it will ever be and
to me it really will depend on who
drafts him because when you get a chance
and again because I had eyes on Trey
young he is he has a skill set and we
all know that he has a fantastic shooter
I was calling him baby Curie because he
makes a lot of the same passes and comes
off the screens that can shoot from
30-plus feet but he's not as big as
Steph was when he was at Davidson mm-hmm
Steph was a little bit taller skinnier
but a little bit taller Trey's a little
bit smaller and it was very difficult
for him to get some of those shots off
versus Rhode Island and if he's if it's
difficult for him to get the shots up at
the collegiate game is gonna be much
difficult at the next level but I think
he can mature into that because we said
the same thing about stuff and we all
have seen what has happened and
transcribed since but I think it depends
on which organization in which system
drafts him talking to Reggie Miller he's
got games in the regional finals
Thursday night you'll have Michigan and
Texas A&M and then Gonzaga against
Florida State
McLovin has an NBA Western Conference
theory that he would like to run by you
McLovin well not so much a theory but
I'm looking at the teams like Utah and
Portland and OKC or red-hot that they
may be able to knock off Houston or
Golden State before the Western
Conference Finals that's a great theory
but I just can't see any one of those
teams in a seven-game series now
remember both Golden State and Houston
would have home court advantage
throughout those series between a Utah
or a Portland as fantastic as Lillard
and McCollum and Terry Stotts coaching
at Portland team well I think that
they're up to thirteen or fourteen
thirteen as of last night versus the
Clippers and Spyder Mitchell what he has
done it in his rookie campaign because
for a while there remember go there had
missed a lot of games and Utah was what
like almost eight or nine games out of
the picture
now they're up to I believe six in the
West I can't see it beating one of those
two juggernauts in the West I think they
can take them six games maybe but I
think they're on a collision course
though as those two meteors are headed
towards one another did you hear the
news that tyronn lue is gonna step down
coaching but for the time being a leave
of absence because their health issues
number one yes I did and number one I I
hope he finds out what's actually been
ailing him I know this has been going on
for a while he's missed at least three
games that I can remember where he had
to leave the bench during a game it's
some type of heart issue from what I've
been hearing so first and foremost you
hope they can give him a definitive
answer of what is wrong I know he's
going to be on some type of medication
that gonna probably take its toll on him
be a little bit taxing so I think he
needs the time away but again we've seen
this kind of with Steve Kerr a few years
back when Luke Walton took over and the
success he had and then just last year
when Mike Brown took over it can be done
Larry Drew is a former NBA coach so he
has experienced in that seat and again
they have LeBron James who is the
de-facto coach as well who people claim
here so do you see them before do you
think and I don't know if this is true
or not it feels like there's more
complaining about the officiating this
year than in recent memory whether it's
coaches and certainly players where am i
just you know because it's fresh that it
feels like it's it's newer you're not
imagining it and at one point there was
talk about the players having a I guess
a summit at all-star break with the
officials which I thought would have
been a disaster I like being a player
that always constantly jabbered at the
officials I get it
I see both sides because there are some
bad calls there really is and we even
would instant replay when the fan had a
chance to go back and say that was a bad
call I think it puts a little bit even
pressure on the officials you just hope
we can't use it as a crutch at the end
of the day saying the officials are
determining outcomes of the games
because players are but I get it I
understand I see the frustration Randy
do you say you've got to give the
players a license to react this game is
all about reaction at times do we go
overboard yes
I'm speaking to you mr. draymond Green I
think he pushes the envelope because I
love dream on
I could always play with dream on Coach
dream on I would always want to be on
dream on team but at times he pushes the
envelope a little bit and I think that's
where the frustration from both sides
kind of set in well you know I watched
James Harden a lot and I I'm always
curious because he doesn't make like
flashy moves but he has he has the
hardaway forearm down pat reg where you
know Timmy would kind of create
separation with that Harden does that
all the time but it's never called why
James Harden might may be the hardest
person and I'm gonna put him in the same
breath as Shaquille O'Neal the hardest
people to ever officiate because a lot
of times they initiate most of the
contact yeah and James Harden along with
Michael Jordan probably gets fouled on
just about every play but you can't call
every play can't call every foul and
both of those players Shaq and James
they use that because you have the
opposing coach and players saying look
how are we going to stay in front this
guy without being able to put our hands
on them at times and play with our hands
up because basically you know having
this conversation with Steve Kerr
they're telling their defenders you have
to guard them with your hands up that is
almost impossible to do as a defender to
go against James Harden with your hands
back and just moving your feet you've
got to be able at times to put hands on
them to kind of dislodge up and throw
him off balance once he starts to go
into that dance and gets going moving
forward
towards the basket maybe the most
difficult player James Harden to
officiate maybe ever
along with Shaquille O'Neal that this
game has ever seen there's a multiple
reports Penny Hardaway is going to get
the coaching gig at Memphis is his alma
mater if he had stayed healthy reg penny
sensin first ballot hall-of-famer easily
I mean could do everything I know people
like to compare him to Magic Johnson
they were different type tall guards
penny was special because he saw the
floor like magic but I thought he was a
better score and maybe post-up player
than magic and to remember him and
Shaquille at a young age
I know at a young age I mean we had our
battles back in the early 90s going
against those guys we were fortunate to
beat them but penny was just a rookie so
I knew the following year or once he
figured it out and they took us to seven
games and beat us in in seven games so
yeah he would be a first-ballot Hall
form this is a great opportunity for him
I mean I know he's been coaching at the
high school level there locally but this
is a big step for penny because now I
think if they can keep a lot of those
recruits in that Memphis area going to
Memphis I think this is a potentially
could be a great hire for Memphis I
forgot this story when Shaq was shooting
blue chips and c-webb was going to do it
but he but he said he decided not to
because he had the disasters timeout
against North Carolina in the title game
and decided you know let me sit this one
out
so Penny Hardaway takes Chris Weber's
place as they shoot blue chips and Shaq
was all in on c-webb telling c-webb
we're gonna we're gonna take you number
one overall and then all of a sudden
Shaq starts playing with Penny Hardaway
and he didn't call c-webb back it was
like we're taking penny
[Laughter]
and I and you know penny was the right
guy for Shaq it didn't turn it up
because of the injuries I mean see Webb
turned out to be a better Pro but penny
penny and Shaq could have been something
really really special flora stretch
there Penny Hardaway remember the Penny
Hardaway doll and the whole Tyra Banks
famous Raj being the voice of the it was
he was part of the face of the league
along at the same time Grant Hill the
first six years of Grant Hill
spectacular spectacular face like they
were handing the mantle Jordan was on
his way out and Penny and grant were
getting ready to be the face of the
league and then injuries kind of
derailed both of those players at their
best Grant Hill or Scottie Pippen Oh
Lord it's system it's system because if
you put grant with Michael I think they
had the same success don't you think I
think Scotty was probably a better
defender yeah but in terms of all-around
play and score Grant Hill his first year
for his first six years I mean he was
the best of all four at the time over
Scottie his first six years body of work
Scottie Pippen did you ever a sight from
Jordan did you ever have what happens
when you have one of those helpless
moments where you know you're just gonna
get embarrassed by somebody who has one
of those nights like do I always
remember this to this day and I had one
of those and it was against Ron Harper
before Ron Harper joined the Bulls when
he was considered the second or third
best shooting guard he was playing with
the Clippers and he was just a year
removed from the knee surgery and I'm
coming home have 50 family and friends
in the building of the old Sports Arena
and Ron Harper absolutely gave me the
business that day know you're gonna
you're gonna get you know especially
after shooting our position you know my
turn your turn you're gonna have your
moments but that was a game that I
vividly remember I could absolutely do
nothing against him and he torched me
for like 42 to my 15
in front of salt and Kari and Tammy and
Durrell it was it was pretty
embarrassing but yeah you have you have
those own you have those moments I just
can't imagine what it was like to be on
that Raptors team when Kobe puts up 81
right awesome all right
that is kind of awesome no I mean the
feelings and they needed all 81 of those
points to win that ballgame right it
wasn't like they were running up the
score that was a comeback victory for
the Lakers well that's why he was able
to stay in and continue shoot only when
a guy gets that many points it's a
blowout and they'll sit him down but you
know they they actually needed him in
there but well let me ask you let me ask
you this okay and this could be a poll
question which one is more impressive
the 81 by Kobe or the 60 in his last NBA
game which one would you take if I could
say goodbye with 60 and never come back
or be second behind wilt with 81 I'm
gonna take 81 I'm gonna take 81 I mean
that's that's like that's stratosphere
stuff man we will never ever ever in any
professional sport ever see a farewell
game like so you would take the 60 as
they would take the because this is the
last memory and image we you will ever
have of me 60 at how old was he at the
time 38 39 dead legs
a busted Achilles 60 I'm giving you 60
I'm putting I'm putting 81 on you 81 but
there was a lot of games out yet 81 good
bye 81 drop the mic but 61 people we
were expecting him to be great when he
got 81 we are you have in your last game
ever that was the loss to Detroit in the
playoffs I believe I had 28 and I
dropped the mic mm-hmm that was the best
I could do at 30
nine with a short-handed so we didn't
have her on our chest wait who was on
you hey Sean Prince rip oh yeah you
could score on rip come on no rip was
good no rip was a and they had that
Larry Brown defense know they had a
great defense hey Sean rip Chauncey I
drive the lane Ben Wallace no they were
they were solid 28 28 drop of the Mike
maybe 27 but who's counting
well but we're gonna look and what is it
Paulie you got it I don't have the
numbers but I think I see tears after
the minute after there you went you have
a towel right there was probably more
tears than buckets because that was it
that's my point 60 cryin last game 60
crying last night we saw Kobe Bryant he
dropped 60 we're not saying oh my god
Kobe Bryant got 81 last game with all
the stars in the building everyone came
out to see Kobe that was his last game
and he gives you a performance like that
income oh man I want to go out like that
and birds giving you a standing ovation
the crowd to stand up as you as you walk
off the court there that's pretty cool
with Larry legend saying hey let's give
a standing ovation here okay how many do
you have McLovin
27 okay I want 81 all right I gotta go
have fun next round will be watching on
Thursday night you're the best Thank You
reg it's 60 that is an interesting poll
question for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you